I'm going to start on it. Yeah, it'll be really good. So all right. So let's get started. I'm going to mute everyone with the exception of myself here.
And today we're going to talk about the topic of fasting. So let me just try and get rid of that over there.
Yeah, put this down first.
I'll move it over there. Okay.
So we decided to talk about fasting today because it's just gaining so much steam everywhere. We turned Dr. Connors and I were learning more and more about fasting. There's just tons of research out there about it. And what we get a little nervous about is that sometimes when things get really popular, such as, you know, new trends, ketogenic fasting, all kinds of different things throughout time.
And then people, especially health care practitioners are quick to dismiss fads. So I want to make sure that we do a webinar, a zoom call about fasting so that we can definitely address some of the truths about it. And then we're also going to go into the myths about it, because that's important.
To sort that out as well. So we'll go through that. And if you guys have any questions, we'll save them for the end. So what are we going to learn today. So we're going to learn the truth about the fed versus fasted states and how insulin and glucose work together, fasting and metabolism, we're going to learn about eating frequent many meals or snacks and how they relate to fasting and the insulin and glucose.
Fasting and gut health, we're going to talk a little bit about timer-stricted eating. And I did write an article and I posted on Facebook about that. So if you want some more information, deeper information on that, you can go to the Facebook page. But I'm going to cover the gist of the timer-stricted eating. And we're also going to mention the fasting mimicking diet because you know at the clinic, some people are put on the fasting mimicking diet.
And we're just seeing a lot of really good stuff with that. I'm actually attending a really big conference in Florida tomorrow. And one of the topics is intermittent fasting and the fasting mimicking diet. So a lot of really good research behind that. So before we get started on talking about fasting, I want to put out the disclaimer that fasting is definitely not for everyone.
We have people that are in a state where they really need to be eating. And sometimes that's called cacaxia where their bodies in that state where fasting would not be, it would not be a good idea, good strategy for them. So definitely, if you want to double check with us at any point, if this would be a good thing to implement.
Especially if you're, you're diabetic. So people with diabetes, I really prefer that they work one on one with a practitioner, such as myself. I have walked people through this. But really, we have to be really careful with people with diabetes issues because of the blood sugar issues. And it can be dangerous if we drop our blood sugar too low.
So if you have diabetes, so let's, I'm just going to throw that disclaimer out there there before we get started.
But for most people, we get to be able to fast. And it's really extremely good for our bodies. So your body is designed to smoothly transition between two different and opposing states, the Fed and the fasted.
And the Fed state insulin is elevated and this signals your body to store access calories in your fat cells.
And the presence of insulin, the burning of fat is stopped. And while the body burns glucose instead from your last meal.
And the fasted state insulin is low, the body starts mobilizing stored fat from your fat cells and burning this fat for energy.
So this is not at all about weight loss. I just want to say right now, is that a lot of this I do talk about burning fat. And I'll mention that. But really the goal is not to just look better in your swimsuit. That's coming up this summer.
The goal is to be healthy, to be less inflamed, to have your body systems working optimally. So although I'm going to talk a lot about a lot about fat burning. It's, it's really goes a way beyond, you know, just just that mechanism. So really.
In the United States, it actually, you know, not just us, I won't play a must. But just as a, as the world, I would say, we're spending less and less time in that fasted state.
So, you know, unfortunately, that that's not good for our bodies. So our bodies in our cells spend less and less time than mobilizing and burning the stored body fat for energy.
And the glucose burning pathways are way overused. And eventually what happens is insulin's high all the time because insulin is that hormone that will escort glucose into the cell.
So it's high all the time in the body avoids burning stored fat, relying mostly on glucose.
And over time, this chronic exposure to so much insulin also leads to insulin resistance where the body secretes even more insulin in response to the fed state.
And then chronic insulin resistance. It's the cause of metabolic syndrome. So that's obesity, abdominal fat storage, high triglycerides, low-H.
I have a very good day or the good cholesterol and elevated glucose with eventually resulting in type 2 diabetes. And I was reading and researching for this talk, and I came across a statistic that said, one in 12 humans on earth currently have full blown type 2 diabetes, well 35% of adults and 50% of over older adults have metabolic syndrome or pre diabetes. And I'm like, whoa, wow, what is going on here?
And so, you know, you really look at the ramifications,
the really negative ramifications that we've got ourselves
into in a society that eats in the patterns,
that the way that we're eating right now
is the frequent meals and the high carb meals
that we're just not getting into that fat burning
and that takes away from the glucose burning.
So, we know that fasting is good.
It has a lot of research behind it.
I'm going to mention some of that.
But it's hard.
It's really hard to start fasting.
I remember about 15 years ago, I was in college
and the Atkins-Dike got really popular.
And at this time, I was eating fruity pebbles
and white bread, wonder bread.
And I was what you call a sugar burner.
So, I really had not used any of my fat burning pathways
because I was just that's the way I ate.
That's just what I had access to.
And I really guess I didn't really know any better.
So, when I tried to start on even just the Atkins-Dike,
so it's just stopped just stop burning the glucose
and get into the fat burning, I thought I was going to die.
I felt like death.
And I remember I was out and about
and I thought I have to pull over and get a coke.
So, I pulled over the gas station
after being on cheese and steak and hamburgers
for a couple of days.
Got a coke and I felt immediately about her.
And that's a really bad sign.
It's a bad sign if you have problems going low carb
and you feel terrible.
That's just a red flag that you probably need
to get out of your sugar burning state
and get more fat adapted.
So, I put down low-er carb diet
because you know that in our clinic,
we don't have any quote unquote protocols.
Everyone is different.
Everyone in their metabolism and their genetics
and how they handle fats and carbs and proteins.
Everyone's a little bit different.
So, we work really hard
and we're very specific about prescribing a diet
because again, it's not that everyone should go vegan
or everyone should go ketogenic.
That's not the answer.
So, really, what we're talking about is fasting
and then when you're not fasting,
the food that you're eating is going to be different
for everyone, but the fasting is the same.
But what can help you, so this slide is about
what can help me fast is that if you're not having
these high carb components in your diet
that are spiking your insulin.
So, if you're choosing things that are lower in carb,
you're not gonna have as big of an insulin spike.
And then it's gonna be easier
because we know we get that insulin spike
when we eat high glucose foods,
then our insulin just comes out,
gobbles up that glucose,
we actually can get a drop in glucose
so we feel kind of yucky.
So, really kind of starting, if you're gonna start out,
just think more.
And if you're already eating this way, awesome,
if you're not, it is a good strategy
to go a little bit lower carb.
So, just try and start making choices
that are a little bit lower carb,
so you're kind of flattening out your blood sugar.
Exercise definitely can help with implementing fasting.
Just get your cells more,
they're more sensitive to glucose.
So, exercise is always a good idea,
but again, it's different for everyone,
not everyone can exercise.
Avoid it, process foods is really important
for that same reason that we just wanna get our bodies
not so that it's such a shock
when we're trying to go into fat burning mode.
And the best advice I can give anyone
is that practicing this is how you get good at it,
like anything, is that you start slow,
you really respect your body and how it's processing
and the signs it's giving you
and you really start off really slow.
So, if that means stopping eating after dinner
and then getting eight o'clock in the morning,
and if that's different for you,
if that's a little bit more of the,
what's called the time restricted eating,
start there, just try and start pushing it out
and it is it's a metabolic workout
and that's what the name suits it
is that we're trying to extend the time
that we can stay fast and stay utilizing fast
because it's super extremely healthy,
it has a really a lot of really good benefits.
But before I go into those benefits,
I know where my mind goes,
I've always questioned things
I kinda got some trouble in high school and in college
because I was always questioning like,
well what does that mean and what does that mean?
And if I had anything in my mind that I was questioning,
I couldn't quite pay attention to what they were talking about
because I'm thinking about, wait a minute, what about this?
So what I wanna do is I wanna clear up some of the fasting myths
and then we can talk about all the benefits.
So then you can go, okay, all right, I get that.
I get to understand that that's a myth and then you'll go,
oh, okay, that makes much more sense with the benefits.
So the first one is eating many meals and snacks.
So eating frequently, this is just short and sweet.
Eating frequently is not good for you period.
So it's not like a blanket statement
but because there's people with diabetes
and there's people who are in that caecctic state
and they need to eat, they need those calories
but eating and these frequent insulin surges,
it's really not good for you.
It doesn't have a whole lot of benefit
in the scientific research.
So when I as a doctor here, Dr. Holderman,
I have to eat very frequently, I just feel terrible.
Do you know what that says to me?
That's the red flag that's waving that says,
well then you need to start learning how to fast
because you're probably just burning sugar
and you need to be more fat adapted, especially with cancer
because it's, you know, the Warburg effect,
it loves to gobble up glucose.
That's its preferred pathway.
So that's short and sweet as eating frequently
like those nibbles and everything.
That's really hard on your body.
You don't ever give it a break.
People say to me, well, I can't fast
because my metabolism really decreases.
Well, guess what?
That's not true at all.
The research would say your metabolism actually increases
when you're fasting.
So I always tell people that, you know,
when you're, let's say you're fasting
and you fast breakfast and lunch and dinner,
you're actually having breakfast, lunch and dinner
and your body's feasting on your fat cells.
So it's going, oh, okay, you're not giving me glucose.
I'm gonna go find some fat cells to chew on
and that's why we're able to sleep at night
and not die in our sleep of salvation
because the body's not stupid.
It goes, oh, okay, well, we're not going to burn sugar
so I'm just going to go munch on that fat.
I really think I'm not going to go down this rabbit hole
but I really believe in sort of Dr. Conner's
that that's what, you know,
if you have that waking up in the middle of the night,
especially around three, two, three in the morning,
that can be because you are not fat adapted
that you are not smoothly transitioning
the fast and fed states that you really need to work on
not being such a sugar burner.
So really, you know, you can give people sleep aids
and melatonin but the first thing I do is we look at their diet
and I have them start tracking their blood glucose
and I have them start really restricting down
their time that they're eating and that helps a lot.
The next myth is that breakfast is the most important meal.
The day, no, it's not the most important meal of the day
and it is okay if you can make it through without breakfast.
Actually, breakfast time when you wake up,
your insulin levels are actually quite low
and most people are actually just starting
to enter the fasted state because it takes 12 hours
after eating your last meal to actually get
into that fasted state.
So that's really a great time to just keep on going.
Now again, let's put the disclaimer out there.
It's not for everybody.
I don't want you passing out.
I don't want, you know, you push yourself to the limit here
but really just keeping this in mind
of the health benefits is a really good idea.
So your gut health, so this is important
to guts the foundation of health.
So when we're eating and snacking all the time
from the time we get up, we have a coffee at six in the morning
and we put some creamer in it and, you know,
Steve here, Steve is okay but, you know,
we're still putting the cream in there
and then we're having something for breakfast
we're having an egg and then at 10 o'clock
we're having a protein bar.
Your digestive system needs a break.
It needs time to repair and needs time to detoxify
so that really plays into your liver as well
and we're looking at fasting in the research
we'll cut your inflammation.
So whether we like it or not and I've said this before
every time we eat we're getting an immune response.
We're putting something for an entire body.
Our body has to decide if it's friend or foe.
We're challenging.
Sometimes we think that, you know, let's say for instance
it's okay to have gluten and then we eat it
and your body is really not quite sure
and then it can cause inflammation.
So giving your body a break can help to kick on
what's called that autophagy and that's that cleaning.
So that's the cellular waste debris,
the old proteins, everything from, you know,
the old collagen and your knees to your brain
that autophagy kicks on to really clean that out
and fasting really helps push that pathway.
So now some of the proven benefits of intermittent fasting
promotes fat loss and again that's really not the point.
I really want everyone to be healthy and feel really good
and I want everyone's cancer not to be fed
and those are really what I'm we're looking for as practitioners
but it does promote fat loss.
Improves insulin sensitivity, improves your metabolism,
starves the bad bacteria and the colon,
promotes longevity, improves hunger.
So there's a researcher by the name of Dr. Jason Fung
and he really does a lot of research on the cravings
behind intermittent fasting and the fasting with cravings
and that really the the best thing you can do
is just completely go cold turkey with some of these foods
that you crave not to have just little tiny like,
oh, I love bread, I can't give up bread
and then just to have a little bit of bread here and there
he said, that's like giving a heroin addict
who's in remission just a little bit of heroin
it just doesn't work so the benefit of the fasting
is to just break those cravings that aren't good for you
really, really fast.
I can improve mindful eating appreciation of your food
and we know that fasting is biblical as well
so that plays a really big role in and and that
so we'll talk about that a little bit later.
They can improve the eating patterns,
our brain function, our immune system fights,
cancer cells those that are glucose dependent
can reverse diabetes, improve fatty liver,
improves neurodegenerative disorders,
reduces inflammation, improves cellular regeneration
and repair, improves lipid parameters,
normalizes blood pressure, improves allergies
and it has rest for your digestive organs
so just a ton of really positive effects
of doing something that's really simple and free.
So time restricted eating,
so this is different than intermittent fasting
so intermittent fasting I will say is an umbrella term
so intermittent fasting does not have a hard fast rule
of 12 hours, 18 hours it just means an extended
amount of time that you are taking a break from food
so time restricted eating is something that cancer patients
that we're trying to get cancer patients to commit
to not just an intermittent fast here and there
but that we're restricting down our eating time
to a specific window so it's really important
because again we don't enter the fasted state
we don't get that benefit until about 12 hours
so if you finish eating at 7 p.m.
when you get up in the morning
and you're gonna eat breakfast it's you're just starting
you're just starting that that positive effect
so ideally and an ideal world
and I probably adhere to this you know 80% of the time at least
but I had to practice it would be stopping eating after dinner
and then slowly implementing and if you now I'm more of like
okay let's get this done let's just start at 12 p.m.
but some people like I said they're gonna have to just
just kind of broaden the window out
so and try and get to that six hour window is really ideal
why I'm really a proponent of this is because of the research
it's really it's apparent it's right there
so in my article on time restricted eating
you know the research will show that you know
in these time restricted fed mice okay it's mice
but we're looking at you know humans and we're looking at
but they have published us that the tumors won't grow
as much as the if the mouse restricts the the eating time
and what's cool about that is that if you take every
all the food you're gonna eat in one day typically
let's just say you eat breakfast lunch and dinner
and you have some snacks and then you put it on a table
and you eat your normal amount of food
so you ate that food from seven a.m. to seven p.m.
if you take that same amount of food
and you restrict it to about eight to six hour window
the research is showing that even though you're not changing
the calories you're not changing the content
that you are going to be losing weight
and that makes sense from everything I just said
because once you get past that 12 hour
and you're into the fat adaptation
where your body's having your fat cells for lunch
and it's happy about it
then you're going to have those positive effects
and the inflammation is going to go down in the markers
those markers are inflammation you can see in the research
they go down and that's really exciting
not only that with the cancer side of it
is that you get the improved glucose metabolism
improve lipid profiles
a cholesterol gets better
you increase your lean muscle mass
decrease fat mass and decrease fatty liver
and get favorable gene expression
I will say that a lot of people
they say I don't want to fast
because I don't want to lose lean muscle
because it just gobbles up my muscles
so that's another myth as well
is that it's not going to go after your lean muscle
you have a lot of other protein that's hanging around
and your body's really smart, it was made by God
it knows it needs to go after the old proteins
that hanging around that's not good for you
that needs to be cleaned up
and it will go after that
so the fasting mimicking diet
so I don't want to reinvent the wheel here
so Dr. Conner's webinar on this is really, really good
we really like the fasting mimicking diet
because again of the research
because it's showing that if you do these five days
on the fasting mimicking diet
per month for three months
that you will have a positive effect
in a couple of different markers
and those effects can be seen down the line
even when you're not necessarily doing the fasting anymore
the data is saying that you get those effects long after
so we're proponents of it
there is a concern that if you go over 24 hours of fasting
and you have cancer that you're gonna kick on
a higher amount of growth hormone
and if you have cancer that's not necessarily a good thing
so I would say with Dr. Conner's and I
were having a conversation about this today
that we don't want to go over 24 hours on a water fast
if we have cancer because of that growth hormone issue
we'd rather have you do the fasting mimicking diet
and again just look up on the Zoom call
or on the Facebook page just look up
fasting mimicking diet and you'll see
Dr. Conner's webinar on this
I'm about to embark on this
so wish me luck on the diet
I typically fast 24 hours once or twice a week
so but that took me some time going from fruity pebbles
all the way to that it did take me some time
so but I really see the benefit
I'm sleeping better I talked to you guys about how I track
my sleep with a it's called an aura ring
and the fasting on the days I fast
I get much more deep sleep
and I've been getting a lot more deep sleep
just because I think I'm more fat adapted in general
I'm not doing a whole lot of high carbs at all
and just helping my body have that smooth transition
so if there's any questions on that fasting mimicking diet
just we'll talk about it after the webinars over too
so this is new so what we're gonna do
because we are we're excited about about fasting
we think that again everyone
we don't give a blanket statements
but guess what this is one you're gonna hear from us
is that the timer's stricted eating
really tighten up that window is good for everybody
pretty much we that across the board
but the the internet fasting
okay that's a little bit different that's on case by case
but if you are able to do some fasting
if you feel comfortable if you want to start
we're gonna start doing community fasting
and this is actually gaining popularity
in some other groups
and so we thought well why not we have an awesome community
we all love each other we all support each other
we're on Facebook and so every Sunday after dinner
we're going to start fasting as a community
we're going to start some time after dinner
now that's different for everyone
and we're gonna have the Facebook support on there
so we'll have prayer requests
so it's gonna be a day of prayer and fasting
and if you can get to you know from dinner
to eight o'clock in the morning
and and that's as far as you can go
well that's awesome and you know so we're not saying
that we're gonna go everybody after dinner
has to start for 24 of fast
that's not what we're saying at all
it's just a day to reflect
to really support each other
to really come together
and you know as a community we're just we're so happy
that we can support each other
that we know that we're in this together
and we think this is a really good way to connect more
and again so we'll start that off this Sunday
I'll write on there and I'll write some prayers
that I would love for you guys
whether you're faster or not
to help me out with and for the clinic
so look for that
and we're excited about it
so I'm gonna open this up
to questions
okay guys you have the floor
does anybody have any questions?
Dr. King, you have one
I'm gonna write the time we stick the diet
I've been on it maybe
real strict, I'm going real close for about a week
I'm getting tired
and I'm feeling that I can't get a whole white food here
at that window
okay so do you own a glucometer
something you could check your blood glucose with?
you know
okay so that that really helps to guide you
to see where you are with blood glucose
and how your body's responding
to the different diet
now it could be a little bit of
you're trying to get into more fat-up adaptation
so your body's like I really like burning sugar
because I can last a while
or it can be like you said
you're just not getting in the right amount of calories
I mean a lot of people we do not want
we don't want them fasting
or we don't want them doing time restricted eating
and necessarily losing a ton of weight
so we don't really
and it's really the weight that needs to be lost
we're talking about like the extra pounds
if you take a body builder and you do time restricted eating
which they do
they're not they're not going to lose a ton of weight
so really it's more for the extra
so what I would do is I would start tracking your blood glucose
and I would also start
widening out your window
you may have gone a little bit too fast
so just kind of give yourself two extra hours to eat
and see how you do with that
Okay, would you call that glucon what?
A glucometer, just a blood glucose
Okay, measure.
All right, thank you.
Yeah.
Dr. Hall-Derman, if you're doing the time restricted eating
is it okay to drink dandelion tea
or coffee or something in the morning?
So the research is a little bit fuzzy on this
but most of the science says that coffee, tea, water
and they go as far as saying that like a sparkling water
with sweetened with like stevia is actually okay
and I would say this as I would what I have done
and I know that people are different
in what will spike their blood sugar
so sometimes it's strange as it sounds that
one sweetened coffee like just completely normal coffee or tea
will actually cause a bump in glucose
and so you could just test yourself
so you could take your, you know, prick your finger
see your blood glucose is at have your glass of tea
and then do it like about five minutes later
and then see what it's at
and if it's about the same, you're good.
Okay, good question.
Okay, almond milk is that okay in the coffee?
So almond milk will actually stop the,
it'll stop the mechanism fasting
so you'll go back into the fast, yeah.
Okay, gotcha.
Thank you.
Yeah, good question.
And it's 16 to 18 hours, is that ideal?
Yep, that is correct, yep.
And again everybody's a little bit different
so there's people who are like,
I can't afford to lose another pound.
So then you then if you're doing a six hour window
but you're losing weight, then you gotta go,
okay, well, maybe my body'll be better in an eight hour
try and stabilize out, you know, out where you are.
Right.
Okay.
Does anybody have any other questions
other than the fasting and the timer's restricted?
Yeah, this is that again.
Can I ask a question about the fasting memory king diet?
Sure.
I have a histamine problem
and everything that the ingredients they have on those
and that is, you know, say they should be eating that stuff.
But I tried that done two, one, three months
and then waited three months and then another three months
and it seems to be okay, but when I get done,
I seem to want to gobble everything.
Okay.
Yeah, I would say that if you're not,
so you're doing, you're doing okay,
you're not having a huge system in response
and you're actually on the diet,
is that what you're saying, Deb?
Not yes and no, but people saying they have
like the second or third day, they have a herxmeyer kind
of reaction, same thing here, but nothing I can't get through.
Okay.
Yeah, but then when you go back to eating,
you're starving to death.
When I go back to eating, it's like, give me food.
Yeah.
Yeah, here, yeah.
You know, I think that's called normal.
So.
So, you know what, I think the best thing to do would be
you can, it's important to ease your way back
into especially high carb things or even just carbs.
So start off with a really like an avocado
and then give yourself an hour, just kind of, you know,
and then some coconut oil, if you can't really try
and just keep like, remind your body
that this is the way the state we want to be in
and so don't go back to carbs as much as, you know,
that sounds really, really good.
I think that's where people crash
as I actually happened to my husband.
He went on a fast and then he was starving to death
so he ordered pizza.
Yeah.
He.
That's it.
That's all right.
Go ahead.
That's what she did.
She died.
Yeah.
She did it.
Oh.